[Music]  i still can't believe it  you're gonna fall in love with a new  little person again  just breathe  i'm gonna count down from three  and on three  and two and one  [Music]  i can't lie to my family anymore  [Music]  the second you tell your wife that you  are dying  your opportunity to do this is gone  [Music]  you want to go say hi  [Music]  [Music]  so he has everything even the memories  you store deep in your subconscious  do this with us and let life go on for  your family a clean swap  what's going on  you have an opportunity here i'm not  done i didn't say he could not die  feel like i fallen in love with her for  the first time again  you don't like this you think i like  this being told i'm not me because  you're not me  you are not  i love you cam antenna  [Music]  you